I had a company reach out and ask if I would like to
try their juicer.
Thought it would be perfect to try out.
Okay. So far,
it is working great.
I'm loving it.
I thought it would just be
fun to experiment with some apples,
so I'm just gonna add apple juice,
mix it with my celery juice,
and I'm gonna peel them first.
Okay. I'm really impressed with this little juicer.
I think it's great.
It's loud, but it's just as loud as my other juicer.
And this one takes up,
like, hardly any counter space.
My other juicer is massive, and it was, like, $200,
so I like this.
There's all the junk.
We're all done with
my first batch of juice from this little juicer,
and I have to say, I am very,
very pleasantly surprised by how well it works.
And you can go check it out.
I think it's on sale right now,
so be sure to look into that.
This one is so simple,
and I love it so far.